-Now, Tom, you have
a bit of a reputation
for accidentally giving away
spoilers for your movies,
so I thought it would be fun
to turn that skill into a game.
It is time for
"Instant Spoilers."
♪ -Instant spoilers,
instant spoilers ♪
-Alright. Now, we each
have a stack of cards
with names of movies on them.
When it's your turn,
you draw a card
and have to shout out
a spoiler for that movie.
The other person
tries to guess the movie
based on only the spoiler.
The goal is
to guess as many movies
as possible
before the timer runs out.
We're playing as a team.
You ready for this?
-Okay. Yes, let's do this.
-Tom, since you are the spoiler
expert, you'll guess first.
Let's get 30 seconds
on the clock.
Let's get as many as we can.
Ready? And go.
-"Citizen Kane."
-Oh, wait.
-Wait. What?
-What?
-Oh, hang on a minute.
[ Buzzer ]
-Wait, you're going first?
-I thought you said
I was going first,
and then I started to read it
out, but then I realized
I just read out
the title of the film.
-[ Laughs ]
-I just shouted out
"Citizen Kane."
That's not how it works.
-No, you have to
give the spoiler.
-Right.
-The way the game --
[ Laughter ]
The game's already --
So already you've messed it up.
But, yes, the spoiler would be
"Rosebud" probably.
But, yes, correct.
That's it.
But now I will --
[ Buzzer ]
Okay, no, so here's
what's gonna happen.
Now I'm going to try to read
spoilers from my movies
and you're gonna
guess the title.
-Okay.
-Alright. Here we go.
-I'm ready, I'm ready,
I'm ready, I'm ready, I'm ready.
-[ Laughs ]
Ready? And go.
"Luke, I am your father."
-"Star Wars."
[ Ding! ]
-The other one.
-The -- That is "Star Wars,"
isn't it?
I don't know.
-Sure.
-"Empire Strikes Back."
-Yeah.
[ Ding! ]
They did need a bigger boat.
-"Jaws."
[ Ding! ]
-Yeah.
He was dead the whole time.
-"The Sixth Sense."
-Yeah.
[ Ding! ]
Oh, oh, Brad Pitt wasn't real.
-"Fight Club."
-Yeah.
[ Ding! ]
Uh, uh, uh, s--
[ Buzzer ]
I almost said Superman.
-What happened?
-Well, I freaked out because it
was "Spider-Man: Homecoming,"
so it was you and I go --
-Oh.
-They tried to mess with me.
-I'm in that one.
I'm in that one.
I should have got that one.
-I was going to say "Superman."
-Big clue before we get started,
Jimmy.
My first one is "Citizen Kane,"
just so you know.
-We already got "Citizen Kane."
Oh, my gosh.
That one's already out.
But I'm good at this.
Ready? You got four.
I'm gonna get four as well.
Here we go. Ready?
-Okay.
-On your mark, get set, go.
-The aliens are
allergic to water.
No? Okay.
-"Caddyshack."
-She fakes her death
and framed her husband.
David Fitzgerald.
-"Gone Girl."
[ Ding! ]
-The top never stops spinning.
DiCaprio.
-Oh, yeah, "Inception."
[ Ding! ]
-Yes.
I'm in it and I turn to dust.
-"Avengers"?
-Um, yes.
[ Ding! ]
They never actually
made it to the moon.
"Houston, we have a problem."
-"Apollo 19"?
-No.
[ Buzzer ]
-8? "Apollo 7"?
-I'll give you that.
I'll give you that.
"Apollo 13."
-13.
What did I say, 17?
-19 and 8.
-Well, "Apollo 19" was --
The script was amazing.
And they never -- they never
made it or released it.
But you know what?
They should've. Alright.
-They should have done it.
Maybe me and you could make
that film together.
-You know, it's fantasy.
That's the movie business.
It's entertainment, so --
-Love it.
-For this last round,
we're going to see
how many we can get together.
We're going to take turns
drawing cards and guessing.
Alright?
We'll see how fast we can go.
Now, this time you speak first
and I will guess.
-Okay, okay.
-On your mark. Get set, go.
-It's a murder mystery film
and Chris Evans did it.
-Oh, yeah. "Knives Out."
[ Ding! ]
-Yes.
-Okay. Doo, doo, doo.
Mr. Orange is the rat.
Quentin Tarantino.
-Uh...
-Yeah.
-I don't know. I don't know.
-Pass. You go.
-"What's in the box?!
What's in the box?!"
-Oh, "Seven," "Seven," "Seven"!
[ Ding! ]
-Yes.
-A theme park for dinosaurs.
-"Jurassic Park"!
-Yeah.
-He keeps his dead mother
in a rocking chair.
-"Psycho."
[ Ding! ]
She kills Bill!
[ Buzzer ]
She kills Bill.
-Ah, she kills Bill.
She does kill Bill.
[ Ding! ]
-Yes. "Kill Bill."
-I think we get that one.
I think we get that one.
-Five is the magic number!
Tom --
-Thank you, man.
That was really fun.
I enjoyed that.
-Thank you, pardsy.
I'm honored to join you in the
ranks of a true spoiler legend.
"Cherry," everyone,
hits select theaters Friday
and will be streaming on
Apple TV+ starting March 12th.
That's Tom Holland right there,
everybody.